you've been working on this project
since 1999 you've been doing business in
China since 1994 we haven't seen it open
yet we don't know the date but talk to
us about the health of the economy there
we talked so much about the data we get
out of there but the more and more
businesspeople we speak to who are
actually on the ground they are bullish
they watch this transformation to a
consumer based economy do you agree I do
agree we're very bullish on China we
actually believe that the Chinese
consumer is still spending and they and
the Chinese consumer represents as far
as we're concerned a great market for
our company so we're building Shanghai
Disneyland it's scheduled to open
sometime in the spring we will announce
a an opening date sometime after the
first of the year and you know we
believe that we're bringing a product
that's not only high quality but very
unique to that market and that the
Chinese and it will be in demand among
Chinese consumers but has there been any
sort of floating even though it's a high
demand and you're bullish have you
tempered that optimism in any way over
the last six months no we haven't
our our business profile there today is
largely consumer products and motion
picture and neither of those businesses
have shown any signs whatsoever of
slowing down
since all the news has come out about
the Chinese economy so you're still
dealing with a huge population base and
some growth and spendable income and
urbanization and so when when you look
at Shanghai as a for instance and put a
disneyland there in Padang but you have
access to a huge huge population base
hundreds of millions of people over 300
million people will be able to travel to
Shanghai Disneyland within three and a
half hour trip interestingly enough for
did you know that's really quite a large
consumer base and so we're bullish there
most people to go to challenges though
to doing business at that scale inside
China that's not the same so a consumer
products business to make that sort of
capital investment what are the special
challenges there are challenges there
are challenges actually any anywhere in
the world do you try to build something
that is
large you'll have challenges in China
you know we've had a number of
challenges we're bringing a product to
market meaning what we're actually
constructing that's very unique the
structures that we build in a theme park
are extremely complex they're not just
buildings but their shows and their
rides and there has there aren't that
many examples of the Chinese
construction industry building things
that are as complex as what we're
building so I'd say that's really been
the biggest challenge it's getting it
right because what we're building is so
complex but we feel very good about
where we are today and I said we'll open
in the spring and the rest will be
history the magic bands technology the
seamless pay that you rolled out in
Orlando that was successful but also a
big investment well we see that in
Shanghai or has Apple pay mobile
payments kind of made that obsolete well
you'll see in Shanghai is a park that
from a technological perspective is more
advanced than anything we've ever built
that will show up in the attractions
themselves but it'll also show up in
commerce or b2c or c2b transactions so
the consumer will be able to buy their
tickets use their mobile devices
in far more advanced compelling ways
than any other place they from a theme
park perspective that we are today so
Friday was a big day because of the
premiere of Star Wars there was another
little event that happened that affected
your stock price there was a the smaller
stars but still an analyst came out with
a report that expressed some skepticism
involving ESPN in large part I wonder
what your reaction to that report has
been well I was curious or suspicious
about the timing if anybody wanted
headlines the time to do was the morning
after Star Wars opened in the United
States and so it was headline-grabbing
the analysts that came out with that
report has been wrong about us on a
number of occasions and so one would
have to question if he's been wrong so
often before you know how valid were his
comments by the way he's entitled he's
entitled to his opinions and the other
thing I would say I don't know where the
accountability is I don't know when when
he's wrong I don't know who's
accountable for
but the the nothing has changed and
we've got nothing to update since our
less filing our last earnings call
regarding ESPN so again he's entitled to
his opinions I address for us one
specific point I thought I understood
him to make which is you have long-term
commitment substantial equipments on the
sports right side but don't go around
their fixed cost and you've got the
variable costs of subs going down and
that you're caught in a squeeze well
first of all we made a decision to
license those that sports product that
you refer to the NFL and Major League
Baseball in the NBA and the college
football championships to name a few you
know for one main reason that is to
serve the ESPN fan well and really to
essentially perpetuate I guess a
competitive advantage that ESPN has and
to continue to support the strength of
its brand and the consumer proposition
that it makes and so we'd haven't
second-guess that at all our Cable fees
are going up per subscriber but as I
said and we have said we have lost some
subscribers we believe we will continue
to derive growth from ESPN it just will
not be at the rate that we saw before